[Music]
you want to get here
our rebellion is all that remains to
push back the Empire
I think you might be able to help us
when was the last time you were in
contact with your father
what
it appears he is critical to the
development of a super weapon
[Music]
if my father built this thing we need to
find him all right how many do I need
they are requesting a call sign it some
rogue wrote one that we are dealing with
here
in measurable
Empire has this kind of power what
chance do we have
we have hope rebellions are built on
hope
if no idea we're coming
take hold of this moment the force is
strong
make ten menifee like a hundred
take the next chance
you're rebels on you
the dream
you
hey rebel scum is Charlie so new rogue
one trailer let's break it down more Maz
Mickelson more Darth Vader this really
spells the story of the movie out like
the narrative in a much better way than
previous trailers I actually like this
trailer much better you know not just
because we get to see Mads Mikkelsen
but because we also get more darth vader
and we get to hear ben mendelsohn speak
who's playing cranek the person wearing
that white uniform who's presiding over
the construction of the new Death Star
so you see them use the flashbacks to
explain how Jin's father was conscripted
by the Empire to design and build the
Death Star so he's very sympathetic but
he becomes this Oppenheimer like figure
where he makes this weapon of mass
destruction so you kind of wonder what's
going on inside his head but Mads
Mikkelsen is just amazing at playing
very complicated characters or
characters with complicated morality
like he's playing the villain of the
Doctor Strange movie that's coming out
in November before this movie drops in
December so just a quick reminder Doctor
Strange is early November this movie
rogue one is coming out December 16th
for most people and the actual day is
just a little different depending on
where you live but just check like
wherever you usually buy movie tickets
and you'll find out when it's coming out
but you can see from all the different
locations that are just trying to make
this movie look as different from the
main films as possible it's basically
like an anthology film like they want to
tell some of the most iconic Star Wars
movies so I don't know what they're
gonna do with this cast after this movie
we might see them pop up in a sequel to
rogue one but like we know about the Han
Solo movie that they're making that
won't necessarily be connected to this
but will probably involve some of the
same characters but the set design is
amazing the aliens look crazy and I just
can't wait to see all the different
costumes show up at Comic Con next year
like the death troopers probably gonna
be super popular my favorite ghin
costume in this is when she's wearing
the control room operators uniformly she
has that special helmet on that was one
of the weirdest things when I was a
little kid like when you're a little kid
especially when you're watching the old
films you just like absorb all those
designs and you see everybody walking
around in stormtrooper gear they all
look the same like everybody where it's
the same type of helmet but then you see
like really weird one offs like this you
know all you can think of is like why is
this different I don't understand why
they're wearing a
for helmet where can I find the toy for
this that's like the other impulse when
you're a little kid one this is cool I'm
not sure why it's different too where
can I find the toy for this so I
wouldn't be surprised if they have toys
for like every single different type of
costume in this movie we hear a little
more of alan tudyk sassy droid can't
wait to hear more from him he's kind of
like r2d2 if he were giant and made for
murdering people you kind of get the
idea from some of the voiceover from the
rebel characters this is still very
early stage the way they explain is
there's still a bunch of different rebel
cells all over the galaxy that just
communicate very briefly but they don't
actually move around like one giant big
fleet so this is like the Dirty Dozen
Ocean's eleven coming together of a
bunch of different people from different
rebel cells so charting the timeline
with Star Wars rebels this is just like
a little bit after a rebels because
rebels is just like the very beginning
of the rebellion because they only just
start mentioning the word rebellion at
the beginning of that series and I mean
they're a couple seasons deep but all
that stuff is still happening before
what you're seeing here so I know the
big question is is will these characters
show up in the main films the ones that
are happening much much later
chronologically and is this gonna
crossover with rebels like will rebels
characters show up in the movies well I
think if rebels characters are gonna
show up they'll show up during these
anthology films that take place in the
past just because the rebels characters
would be super old by the time the main
films are going on but I do think that
we'll see at least one or two of these
characters pop up in the main films
eventually particularly Felicity Jones
character like I'm really expecting her
to survive the end of this movie to go
on to whatever sequel or other anthology
film but I do think by episode 9 we will
actually see somebody pop up I think
they're just only talking about it right
now they haven't completely figured out
exactly how they want to use characters
from these anthology films but I do
think it'll happen but the one thing
tying these films together right now is
really like the original trilogy
characters like Mon Mothma Darth Vader
just you know very iconic people you
have things like the Death Star just
like big places locations and characters
from the original trilogy so it'd
actually recommend that you watch the
original trilogy again one more time
before you go see this movie
especially a new hope because they're
stealing the plans for that first Death
Star not the second Death Star so when
she says many Bothans died to bring us
this information that was the second
Death Star in Return of the Jedi so in
keeping with that there are a lot of
people I feel are still confused about
what's going on with this film like
people like how come Rey is not in this
this movie is set in the past it's the
story of the rebels stealing the plans
for the first Death Star so if you have
any friends or your parents are like
totally confused about what's going on
with this film just explain to them how
it's a prequel in Star Wars Episode
eight will be coming out next year but
the really cool thing is we are probably
going to get a guardians of the galaxy
trailer either with Doctor Strange or
with this movie so by the time this gets
here we'll obviously get to see a really
awesome Star Wars movie but we'll also
get to see guardians to footage so get
hype and Justice Society is dropping
tonight legends of tomorrow so I'll be
posting my video for that after it airs
there was an Aquaman video that I was
gonna do before this drop but I'll just
do this tomorrow so whole bunch more
comic book stuff happening but if there
are any other Star Wars videos that you
guys want me to do or episode 8 videos
just let me know in the comments what
you guys wait for that supposed you can
click here for that Justice Society
trailer video for tonight's episode and
you can click here for my last big
episode 8 teaser video thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you
[Music]